ROGER MARTINEZ: Does your
app deal with sensitive data?
Do you need to ensure
that it's protected?
Stay tuned.
Find out how easily Cloud
DLP does this and much more.
Throughout this data
loss prevention series,
we're going to focus on our
fictitious feline walking
company, KittyCat Walks.
KittyCat Walks pairs cat
owners with local cat walkers
via their online and mobile app.
KittyCat Walks launched
six months ago,
and it's rapidly
gaining customers.
They want to understand
more about their customers,
both human and feline alike.
And they need a way to share
and analyze some customer
information, like "purr-ferred,"
[CLEARS THROAT] preferred walk
length or favorite catnip, while
protecting sensitive data like
addresses and
credit card numbers.
While this work would be
super hard for humans,
it's pretty easy for Cloud DLP.
Not only can Cloud DLP
automatically detect
addresses and
credit card numbers,
it has over 120
predefined info types.
You can even define your own
based on custom dictionary
detectors or
regular expressions,
so you can protect things
like customer account numbers.
So what sort of
data can DLP scan?
Cloud DLP scans streams
of data, structured text,
files in cloud storage, or data
in BigQuery, and even images.
Once found and classified,
DLP can de-identify the data
using techniques like redaction,
masking, tokenization, date
shifting, and more.
Using the right combination
of these techniques
allows you to preserve
the right data
and still retain some
referential integrity
to collect important metrics and
make smart business decisions.
By adequately
de-identifying data
that we don't need for
any business purpose,
we can minimize the
likelihood of exposure
of sensitive customer
information, which
helps protect our
users and our business.
So what would happen
if we didn't adequately
de-identify our data?
Well, if that data fell
into the wrong hands,
we run the risk of exposing
sensitive information
about individuals, which can
have some serious privacy
implications.
Sounds scary, but Cloud DLP
can help compute and quantify
the risk according
to several metrics.
And it can publish its
findings and summary details
to the systems.
For our catwalk app,
it's clear that we're
collecting personal information
like credit card numbers
and addresses.
But how do we use DLP to help
keep their customer data safe?
Stay tuned for the
next episode, where
we'll cover what is
data de-identification?
[MUSIC PLAYING]